PETE LEPAGE: All right, well,
thanks everybody for joining
us for another edition of our
"Chrome Apps Office Hours."
We're joined today by Renato
Mangini, who is joining us
from Brazil today.
I'm Pete LePage.
I'm a Developer Advocate here
in New York City, working on
Chrome apps.
And It's great to have everybody
join us today.
I think we've got a
pretty interesting
setup for you today.
We're going to be talking about
the WebView Control,
which allows you to embed live
web components within your
Chrome app.
So with that, I'm going to pass
it over to Renato, who
can talk a little bit about
Chrome apps and the WebView.
Renato, whenever you're ready to
share some screens, let me
know, and I'll get us
going from there.
RENATO MANGINI: Thank
you, everyone.
This is Renato Mangini.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Chrome apps.
And I'm talking directly
from Brazil.
Today we will present the
WebView component.
The WebView component,
it's an element.
You put this Element inside
your Chrome packaged app.
And what it does is, it gives
you the ability to embed, as
Pete said, a whole website
inside your application.
This is quite interesting, and
one friend of mine asked me,
why would you want to embed
a website inside your
application?
No, because you are doing
an application.
You are not doing a website.
And there are some compelling
use cases.
We'll talk about that
at the end.
But you can think, like,
testing websites.
You can think about
several other
potential reasons for that.
But we identified two very, very
compelling reasons for
that at the beginning.
The first one--
Chrome packaged app
is new platform.
You who are listening
to us now.
You probably have one website or
one Chrome old packaged app
or a Chrome hosted App, and you
want to use the new APIs.
They are available to Chrome
packaged app and only to
Chrome packaged app.
However, you don't want to--
at the first moment, you want to
create a prototype to show
to your boss or to present to
your customers at first.
And you just want to try
the platform before
committing to it.
So you can create a hybrid
application, where you embed
your application.
You change your code
to detect if it's
running inside the WebView.
And if it does, it uses a form,
a way of communicating
between the WebView and the
platform, the Chrome packaged
app, the real Chrome packaged
app that is
embedded in that WebView.
This is one use case, one
potential use case.
And the other use case that we
are working on to make it very
easy for you to use is
the social network
buttons, the widgets.
Suppose you want to include the
Google+ widget inside your
Chrome packaged app.
Currently you cannot unless
you use the WebView.
Because it uses a series of
embed scripting and things
that CSP doesn't allow
you to do.
And so basically, what we want
to give you here is a way to
include either a whole web
application, or more probably,
a small widget or a small part
of your application inside
your Chrome packaged app and
have all the benefits of a
Chrome packaged app that you
probably heard about.
That's why you are here
listening to us.
So, OK.
Do I have any questions, Pete?
Anything that--
PETE LEPAGE: No, I think that
lays out things really well.
The one thing I do want say
is, as we're going through
this, if you have questions that
you want to ask either
Renato or myself, if there's
things that you're kind of
curious about, we're taking
questions through our Google
Moderator page.
The link's up on the
screen right now.
You can go post your questions
at goo.gl/YfPN5.
Like I said, the URL
is there on screen.
You can go post your
questions there.
We'll be taking those live
towards the end.
And as well, we'll post the
link to some of the
documentation and samples
as we go on.
So, all right, Renato.
Why don't we--
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
So, let's code, right?
Before you switch to my window,
I will show you first
and before everyone else, one
special project I'm working on
that will help you develop
Chrome apps and Chrome
extensions.
It's not ready yet.
That's why we didn't
publish it.
PETE LEPAGE: This is the one
that you've been talking about
internally that you've
shown us--
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's API integration
with some IDEs--
PETE LEPAGE: This is pretty
awesome, guys.
RENATO MANGINI: --especially
Sublime.
But yeah, as I say, it's
very, very early stage.
There are a lot of functions
that are not ready yet.
But anyway, I will start this
project using this project.
I will start the sample using
this project, so you see how
it simplifies things.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, cool.
RENATO MANGINI: So can
you switch my window?
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So they can now see me
with your window up.
And they've got you up in
the top right corner.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes,
all right.
This is Sublime editor.
This is a code editor.
Several people in the front
end would use a lot.
It's very cool.
We've been using it here since
the first GDL session.
And if you have enough
resolution on your streaming,
you can see there is
an additional menu,
the last item here.
It's Chrome, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
RENATO MANGINI: And there
are some options.
And most of the options
are not implemented
now, so never mind.
But anyway, before I start, I
will show the URL where you
can download this extension.
It's not available on Sublime
Package Manager yet.
As I said, it's very,
very early stage.
But in one or two weeks, we
will have an alpha version
that you can try.
So Pete, here are you again.
PETE LEPAGE: Hey, guys.
RENATO MANGINI: Let me show--
yeah, that's it.
That's the URL.
I'm not sure if you
can see that.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, you know what, Renato?
I'll get that up on-screen
in a little bit.
If you can--
RENATO MANGINI: All right.
All right.
Can I go ahead?
Or do you want to--
PETE LEPAGE: You go ahead,
and I'll get the URL.
RENATO MANGINI: All right.
So I will start a new
project here.
It's a Chrome app project.
So I go to Chrome, New
App, and I get
the Hello World sample.
And, ta-da!
You have the base snippets
done, ready for you.
So let's save it here on
my Genie and WebView.
Folder.
That's the live folder,
here, and that's it.
And I saved the Main at the same
directory and the same
for the index.html.
As you probably are aware of,
this is the main structure of
the Chrome packaged app.
There is a JSON, a manifest.
There's a JavaScript, which
is the background page.
The background page is
responsible to open the UI,
the actual UI of your app.
So you listen to this
onLaunched event.
And you do whatever you want.
Usually you just create another
window with the
point-and-shoot correct HTML.
And here we have
the basic HTML.
PETE LEPAGE: Again, this is the
standard stuff that people
are used to seeing.
All you did was create a real
quick way of being able to put
that in so that you don't have
to either go write that
yourself or maybe even
just copy it from
somewhere else, right?
RENATO MANGINI: Exactly.
That's it.
So let's add this application
to my live directory.
And here it is, it's
Hello World, OK?
So let's execute it.
It's nothing different
from the basics.
It's a Hello World
application.
And now we will add the
WebView component.
The WebView component,
it's an HTML
element, as I said before.
It's a simple element.
PETE LEPAGE: So you're
just adding a
WebView tag to your element.
So it's basically exactly like
you would add maybe an iFrame
or something like that.
You're just using a WebView
tag, which normal browsers
aren't going to do
anything with.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
And it's a good thing you
mentioned iFrame, because one
of the most common questions
we get is what is the
difference between the WebView
and the iFrame?
And the difference is, there's
one structural difference, and
there are several consequences
of that.
The structural difference
is the WebView
runs in its own process.
It's a different process than
your main tread, your
JavaScript tread.
What it means is, first,
it's sandboxed.
So you can't load.
And you are safe.
Your application is safe.
You have some--
actually, you have many methods
that you can control
your WebView.
So while we talk, I'm
trying to turn my
other computer here.
So this method allows
you to control--
in fact, there's one sample
on our GitHub repository.
Do you have the URL there?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I can pop that URL
up right now.
RENATO MANGINI: So it's the
sample called Browser.
If you're interested in the
Browser tag, in the WebView
tag, you should take a
look at this browser.
Many things we do here, it's
based on this sample.
And the idea of the sample is
it's not practical, because
it's just a simulation of a
browser inside the Chrome
packaged app.
But it shows you how
powerful it can be.
You can control anything
off the WebView.
PETE LEPAGE: It sort of lets
you build your own browser,
get the idea of how some of
those things might want to
work, how you might use these
things in a real-world
application.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
You don't want to create a
Chrome packaged app that
simulates a browser, right?
PETE LEPAGE: That would be a
little silly, but certainly
something that--
you could do it if you wanted.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah,
you can do it
PETE LEPAGE: Hey, we've
done stranger
things with Chrome apps.
You know, control helicopters,
we've done things like, write
a web server within
a Chrome app.
So effectively, you're writing a
web server within a web app.
So no reason why you
couldn't do it.
Maybe not the most practical.
RENATO MANGINI: Drones
and bacon fryers--
oh, that's not featured yet.
PETE LEPAGE: Hey,
you know what?
If somebody writes a bacon
fryer-controlling Chrome app,
I will feature that in one of
these "Chrome Apps Office
Hours" because that'd
be kind of cool.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah,
definitely.
OK.
So let's see what
happened here.
What I did here, I just
added a WebView.
I set the source attribute,
the src attribute.
The WebView has nothing
inside the tag.
So it's an empty tag.
And I just save it.
And let's check what's happens
when I reload this
application.
Oh, nothing.
Why is that?
So let's check what
happened here.
And you see that this
is planned, OK?
It's not a bug.
PETE LEPAGE: Always
love those--
intentional.
We've got to show you
something first.
RENATO MANGINI: That's true.
It's on my script.
The problem is the WebView
doesn't come with the full
width and height.
It doesn't come with
the full size.
So you have to size it
to properly show it.
And we'll do it using
CSS properties.
It's the only way to do it.
The first version of WebView, if
you looked at some samples
or some documentation before,
you saw the width and height
properties.
But those are not available
anymore, OK?
Let's do some--
I will do two things at once.
I will change the window size,
so we can see the size, the
WebView, properly.
PETE LEPAGE: Reasonably sized.
RENATO MANGINI: Exactly.
And let's change it to--
and that's it.
To make sure that we know the
limits of the WebView, you add
a simple and beautiful
border, right?
And voila, let's see,
reload app, and
there it is, my WebView.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow, that's
a pretty red
border you have there.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
So first of all, if I inspect
this element, this window.
You can see that there's
nothing inside
the WebView, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
RENATO MANGINI: The WebView
uses a shadow DOM.
So it's a very advanced topic,
probably, but anyway, I just
show it here.
It's advanced, the advanced
settings of Developer Tools.
And now, as you can see here,
oh, that's awesome!
So the second feature you
have to remember,
that was planted here--
you think it's a bug.
It's not.
The WebView requires
a permission.
PETE LEPAGE: Aha.
So, one of the really important
things with Chrome
apps is that they work on a
permissions-based model, right?
So we need a permission that
says, hey, we want to do this.
RENATO MANGINI: That's a very
frequent source of errors,
because there is no debugging
information about that.
The WebView element is
simply not available.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's just
kind of frustrating isn't it?
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
There's no error in the
console at all.
PETE LEPAGE: Do you happen to
know, is there a bug filed on
that, Renato?
RENATO MANGINI: If there's not,
it will be in one hour.
I will add it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So that's the other thing.
For those of you guys who
are watching live,
go star that bug.
Go have a look, or
you know what?
Don't even wait the hour.
Go have a quick peek
in crbug.com.
See if you can find it
and file that bug.
Let us know about it so that the
more people who star this
thing, the better chances of
it getting fixed sooner.
And the engineers who are
working on these things know
that it's an important
factor for you.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes, exactly.
So, OK, I added the permission
for the WebView.
And now if I reload the
app, I have here
the Google page because--
why is this Google?
Because I set explicitly the
source of my WebView here.
And as you can see, if I go to
the Developer Tools, after I
enabled shadow root, I can see
the element have this shadow
root, and this is implemented
through a plug-in like
internal implementation.
But anyway, this shadow
DOM doesn't matter
for the normal usage.
Let's get through
how to debug the
content inside the WebView.
Because as you see, you
cannot have access
to the content here.
However, the Chrome packaged
app, you probably noted that
it has one inspector, one
Developer Tool for each
window, for each page
that it opens.
That includes the WebView.
So if we right-click inside
the WebView and we Inspect
Element, here we are.
Now we can inspect the content
inside the WebView.
All right?
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
RENATO MANGINI: So now
let's see what we can
do with this component.
I will copy and paste some code
to make it faster, OK?
But first I will explain what
I'm going to do here.
As I said, the WebView, it's
not a simple iFrame.
I have control over
the WebView.
I can load a specific URL on the
JavaScript code, not only
setting the attribute
on the HTML5.
I can reload the page.
I can stop the loading.
I can receive notification of
events, like if the load
starts, if the load stops.
So let's implement
a very simple
thing that's very important.
If you want to embed a website
inside your Chrome packaged
app, it's very important that
you know when the user clicks
on a link, it makes it load,
and when the load finishes,
which means that your UI
probably wants to show some
stuff to the user based on the
fact that the load finished on
the WebView, right?
So what are we going
to do here?
We're going to include
a script.
And this script, we
will create it.
Pete, can you answer
me one question?
Can I put some scripts here?
PETE LEPAGE: Inside
that script block?
No.
That's another thing that a
bunch of people have run into.
That's one of the Content
Security Policy rules that are
implemented.
You can't, unfortunately, put
script within a script log.
You can only refer to external
script sources.
RENATO MANGINI: Excellent.
Thank you very much, sir.
So this is how--
one more thing I want
to show you.
This is totally unrelated
to WebView, again, OK?
It's a parentheses.
And part of this Chrome app
API integration is code
completion.
PETE LEPAGE: In fact, while
you're doing that code
completion, I'm going to put up
the URL right now, so that
people can go download
this if they want.
The Sublime plug-in you can go
to the URL goo.go/F6dht.
So you can go to that
URL, grab that, and
you can install it.
Keep in mind, as Renato said,
it is a beta stage product.
It's not something that's quite
ready for full-time use.
But it is a great
place to start.
And if you run into questions,
problems, anything like that,
please let us know about them,
because this is something we
want to make your development
and our development on these
apps a lot easier.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah,
absolutely.
So we are back to
the code, OK?
While Pete was talking to
you, distracting you, I
typed out this code.
I'm pretty quick on typing
code, as you see.
But OK.
So let's add one ID to this
element, because I will need
two elements later.
That's why I added an ID.
And this code, it's a very
simple code to get the WebView
and to add infinite listings
to this WebView.
And I have this indicator.
I haven't created it yet.
But I would do it through
div here.
And I want to show loading on
this div, inside this div
every time the WebView
is loading.
And I want to clean
this message
when the load is finished.
So look at this code.
It's very, very simple.
There are two event
listings here.
And I listed these two events.
One thing, this documentation,
this information about events,
properties of the WebView, is
not on the website, on our
documentation website yet.
It's a very new thing, like
one or two weeks.
It's very recent, and we have
technical writers at this
exact moment working to improve
this documentation and
to insert all of these
properties.
That's why I said on the Google+
event, I said come
watch the secrets and
undocumented stuff from WebView.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
So I just put up a URL to
the documentation that
we have right now.
And this is the stuff that, as
Renato said, we don't have all
the final stuff up there yet.
The stuff that he's showing
you here is
not documented yet.
We are working to
get that done.
So keep an eye on that URL
that you see there.
We should have that up
hopefully within the
next week or two.
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
So OK.
What this is--
let's try this code, right?
If there is no typo or copy and
paste error, we will see
this load indicator.
PETE LEPAGE: So we load up.
Boom, boom, boom.
RENATO MANGINI: It
loaded already.
So--
PETE LEPAGE: And we just saw
that loading that showed up in
the top left.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
So let's try some--
look, I'm not sure if the
streaming allows you to see.
But you know--
PETE LEPAGE: We need to find
something slow, that's like,
really, really, really,
really slow.
RENATO MANGINI: Google
is too fast.
PETE LEPAGE: You know, it's
always a benefit when stuff is
nice and fast.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes,
yes, absolutely.
At least this case, we really
would get some benefits from
slow loading.
But anyway--
so see, it's very interesting
because it's two processes.
They are one process in WebView,
one process in your
application.
And they are talking to each
other through these methods.
We haven't shown any
methods yet.
We have shown only the events.
But there are some methods you
can also use to reload
applications, start,
abort, et cetera.
One very important thing here
is since there are two
processes, all the communication
between the
WebView and your web page
are asynchronous.
It's not synchronous, which
means don't expect if you send
a comment like Reload, the
reload will be sent to the
WebView through an internal
post message.
And that process, we'll
get that information,
put it on the queue.
And when it's ready, it will
execute that queue.
So it's not immediately.
It looks immediately but
it's not internally.
So don't think that since you
have methods and not message
sending, don't think
it's synchronous
because it's not, OK?
So now let's change this code
to have a small-- but how--
we are reaching our time so--
PETE LEPAGE: We've got another
couple minutes.
If you want to dive into a
little bit more, no problem.
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
There's one piece of code.
This is more recent than the
events and et cetera, so it
probably will not be in
the next batch of
documentation updates.
But it will be soon, like
in two or three weeks.
There's this concept of
storage partition.
What it means?
Since this is a different
process--
it runs on a different process
operation system-wise.
It cannot--
and for security reasons,
it cannot share the same
partition as your Chrome
packaged app.
What is saved in a partition?
Like cookies, like all
information that is--
it could be persistent, or it
could be session-persistent.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So you're not going to have--
if your WebView stores anything
in local storage,
you're not going to be able
to get that even though--
and actually, that's a bad
example because you don't have
access to local storage
within a Chrome app.
But say, for example,
IndexedDB--
RENATO MANGINI: In fact,
the WebView has.
And that's interesting, because
the WebView, it runs
in a different process.
And that process runs as a
browser view, not as a Chrome
packaged view.
It doesn't have access to the
Chrome APIs, but it does have
access to all the other things
that Chrome packaged apps
cannot do, including if all were
included in local storage
and everything else.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
RENATO MANGINI: RIght?
So local storage cooks, wherever
It's all tied through
your process.
And it's not shared between the
WebView and your main app.
That's all right.
That's the contract.
It's obvious that it should
be like this.
However, I mentioned
that one of the use
cases is for widgets.
And our widget requires
a user to login.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, like if I
want to +1 something, I want
to re-tweet something, I
need to be logged in.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes, exactly.
Suppose your application has a
list of items, like books.
It's a book-reading
application.
And you want to put a +1
button below each book.
But that button is inside
the WebView.
Let's suppose it is inside
Huh.
So you want the user to log in
on each of those widgets on
those WebViews?
No, you don't.
You definitely don't, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that
would be a small pain.
RENATO MANGINI: A small pain?
PETE LEPAGE: It's a polite
way of putting it.
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
So there is this feature.
It's just--
the implementation finished
like last Friday.
It's very recent.
But it's really awesome.
What I do here, and I'm missing
time to implement it,
but it's pretty simple.
I implement it quickly here.
It's this property called
Partition, where you give your
WebView, you put your WebView
in one named partition.
You put whatever name
you want here.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, so it's kind
of like giving it an ID or
something like that.
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
PETE LEPAGE: But it's the
partition name for that area.
RENATO MANGINI: Exactly.
So if you do it on two WebViews
and you use the same
partition name, those will
share the same partition.
So if you login one, the other
will be logged in also.
The cookie will be available
to the second one.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, perfect.
RENATO MANGINI: There
is one a small bug.
I noticed it yesterday while I
was implementing the sample.
That I not try.
I will report today.
Those named partitions should
be-- by spec, they should be,
at least in my understanding,
stored persistently.
So it should be on disk.
It you queue Chrome, if you
queue application, when you
get back, you should have
the cookies back.
The spec says explicitly that
unnamed partitions should use
the memory, a memory
partition.
But named partitions
should not.
So I will talk to the engineers
who implemented
that, just to make sure that
it's really a bug or it's a
feature that we will
implemented later.
But the idea is it should--
in theory, it should keep your
partition safe from restarts.
All right.
So there are several methods
that I could talk about, but
they are all implemented
on the browser tag--
on the browser sample, sorry.
I keep saying browser tag
because the name of the
WebView before was
browser tag.
If you see browser tag mentioned
somewhere else, you
know that it's the
old WebView.
But anyway, it's implemented.
The sample on the GitHub,
it's pretty cool.
It's really complete.
It uses most of the methods.
It doesn't use the partition
because it's a very recent.
PETE LEPAGE: It's brand new.
RENATO MANGINI: But it does
use the other methods.
There is one last feature
I want to talk about.
It's the Autosize.
The Autosize--
I was not showed the whole code,
but it's not implemented
anywhere else, but I'm
working on a sample--
so soon we'll you have it on
the GitHub repository.
The Autosize property,
it's a property
of the WebView element.
When you set it,
it allows the--
when the embedded web page
changes its layout size, it
notifies the WebView element
on the embedder.
There is the WebView content,
which is embedded.
And the embedder, the
host of the WebView,
receives an event of resize.
So you can handle--
you can auto resize.
It's not automatically,
but it's almost--
you receive notifications
that the web
page changed its layout.
The web page embedded
inside the WebView.
This is very, very important
for widgets
that change its size.
For example, the Google+
widget, the
button is very small.
But when you click on the
button, or you hover over it--
PETE LEPAGE: It gets bigger.
RENATO MANGINI: Exactly.
It shows you friends
that +1 the page,
the element, et cetera.
So you can code, and I will have
a sample code for that.
You can listen to this event
and resize your WebView
appropriately.
So it gets current with the
WebView content size, what you
present on your Chrome
packaged app.
And that's it.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
RENATO MANGINI: Any questions
before we start?
PETE LEPAGE: There's a bunch of
really great questions up
on our Google Moderator page.
And as a reminder, the
link is right there.
So you can see it right there.
So the questions are there.
Between Renato and I, we'll
take a bunch of these
questions and do our best
to answer them for you.
So this first question, I'm
not quite sure what the
question's asking, but "I use
this link as well as a branch,
and Pete set the typed WebView
to load HTML app in Chrome to
insert a DOM node security and
control in the body of your
browser." I'm not quite sure
what you're asking there.
And I apologize, I don't know
how to pronounce your name.
Those are characters that,
unfortunately, I can't read.
So one thing that, if you're
looking to insert HTML into
your app that's created
someplace else, you can do
that via a sandboxed iFrame so
that you can run some code
there and be able to use post
message to transfer
that back and forth.
That's one way that you can get
stuff between your app and
another place.
But it takes a little bit
of work to do that.
If you can, maybe repost your
question, if you wouldn't
mind, and provide a little bit
more detail, and we'll try and
answer that.
So go to the next question, and
I'll pass, Renato, this
one for you from Jarek, who's
always asking us some really
great questions.
"Since iFrames are no longer
allowed in Chrome apps, is
there an alternate API that
would allow me to sandbox SVG
documents with synchronous
one-way access from the
top-level document?"
RENATO MANGINI: Well,
Jarek, it's good
that you coded your--
bolded the "synchronous" here.
If you're sandboxing something,
it's very hard to
keep it synchronous, because
if you're sandboxing
something, it's because you
don't trust that source.
And if you're doing it
synchronous, it means that
that source can hang your whole
application by doing
nasty things.
So all the ideas that come
to my mind involve
asynchronous solutions.
However, you can use
the WebView.
If you really want to sandbox
that, you can use the WebView.
And you can create on your
website a page, a web page.
That web page would run on your
website, so that's not
exactly sandboxing.
That reads SVG, and you present
it on your Chrome
packaged app.
So you point to not to the SVG
directly, but you point to
this web page app.
That web page would
connect to the--
would open the SVG.
And you can use Post Message
to communicate between the
WebView and the embedder.
So you have--
this part is asynchronous.
It's not synchronous anymore.
But if you want to-- if there's
anything that you need
performance, that's probably
the reason why you put
synchronous.
You can do it on your web page,
on your website, and
just communicate with the
Chrome packaged app for
passing regular information,
whatever, status, whatever.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
And so I've just got a--
RENATO MANGINI: So one point, if
it's not sandboxed, if you
don't need to sandbox the SVG,
the Chrome packaged app can
show SVG pretty well.
OK?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So Paul Kinlan, one of the
other great Developer
Advocates on our team, just
sent me an IM on my phone.
And his comment was, "If you can
cache the SVG in an HTML5
file system, you can load
it into an iFrame.
And Chrome will treat that as
a local resource." So that's
another option that you can
use if you do that.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
awesome.
PETE LEPAGE: There's a question
that came in on
YouTube that I want to address
because I think it's
actually-- it's always
a good question.
We usually get asked it probably
every other Hangout.
"So why are we using a Mac
instead of Chromebooks?" And
I'll answer part of it.
And Renato, I'll let you answer
some of it as well.
For most of our Hangout
equipment that we use here in
the studio, we actually use
Chromebooks and Chromeboxes.
Renato is connected to
me via Chromebox.
But for me and--
RENATO MANGINI: Can
you see it?
PETE LEPAGE: There we
go, so Renato's got
a Chromebook going.
The only challenge that we
face is doing some of the
screen sharing and getting the
screen sharing hooked up to
our studio.
Because Renato's in Brazil,
I'm here in New York, the
software that we use, it's
unfortunately native software,
and I can't do screen sharing
And then the other thing is,
Renato's got that great
Sublime plugin because we know
some of you are using Sublime.
So that's why we're using
Macs here and there.
But we really do try and use
Chromebooks whenever we can.
RENATO MANGINI: And if you
the user who asked it--
I don't know his name.
I don't have YouTube
open here.
But if you haven't tried a
Chromebook, I know I'm
expected to say that,
but it's awesome.
It's incredibly cool.
You should try, at least.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, especially
the brand-new ones, the ones
that are $250, $249.
It's a really great machine
to have to be able to--
to do pretty much 99% of the
things I want to, I can do on
my Chromebook.
So our next question again
comes from Jarek.
"Does the WebView tag
respect the XFrame
options HTTP header?
If the page was served with the
XFrame option set to Deny,
would the WebView load
it anyway?" I'm
not sure about that.
Renato, do you know?
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
It does not support--
it does not respect.
It shows independently of
what XFrame option says.
Because remember that this
is considered a native
application.
The XFrame options
is for saving the
user from click hijacking.
I think it's the most important
use for that.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
That's a good point.
RENATO MANGINI: But since you're
running it as a native
application, it doesn't
make sense because the
user trusted you.
The user added your
application.
Your application has access to
the hardware of the user.
What's the point of hijacking
the clicks from the user?
And the second point, this
is not the open web.
The Chrome packaged apps are
safe in the sense that they
are distributed in a place
where applications that
doesn't follow the rules of not
stealing information from
the user, not hijacking clicks
from the user, they are
removed from the Web
Store, and the
accounts are suspended.
So if the user trusted you, we
suppose that you don't need to
have those protections
from the open web,
which is more open.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right.
So, the next question.
"Can use NaCl and pass values
to a web page or a web app
held in WebView?
And can you make two pages
held in two different
instances of WebView interact
by exchanging values?
Can you establish session times
out for the WebView-held
pages?"
RENATO MANGINI: There
are three questions.
Let me try to answer
it one by one.
PETE LEPAGE: So the first one
is, "Can use NaCl to pass
values to the page app
held in WebView?"
RENATO MANGINI: Not directly.
You can communication to NaCl
using Post Message.
It's another process.
But you can use either your
background page or the
embedder of the WebView as
a hub of communication.
So you can use a NaCl module,
communicate through the NaCl
embedder the web page or the
background page and have that
page communicate back
to the WebView.
So yes, you can.
But it's not directly from
NaCl to the WebView.
That's a very good point.
We need one sample use of NaCl
on the GitHub repository.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
We had some questions.
And in fact, we don't--
I'll throw this out there.
It's not confirmed, yet, but our
"Chrome Apps Office Hours"
in two weeks, we're trying to
schedule someone to come in
and talk about using NaCl
within Chrome apps.
RENATO MANGINI: Whoa!
That's cool!
PETE LEPAGE: Haven't locked it
yet, but that's the plan.
RENATO MANGINI: Awesome!
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
All right.
Well, let's--
RENATO MANGINI: It's kind of
interesting, because last week
we have this Dart running in
Chrome packaged app sample as
you can see on Git Hub,
and now NaCl.
It's getting quite
interesting.
PETE LEPAGE: We're doing some
cool things, I think.
All right.
Well, let's move on to
the next question.
And actually, there's just about
two questions left, and
I think that's probably the
perfect amount of time.
But "Would it be possible to
implement a mobile browser
emulator using the
WebView tag?
Is there a way to override some
of the device parameters
seen by window.matchMedia or CSS
media queries inside of a
WebView?"
RENATO MANGINI: Jarek,
unfortunately, not now.
But that's one possible idea.
You don't have the access to
the requests, so you cannot
change the HTTP headers yet.
But that's a very
good use case.
I talked yesterday to the
engineering team, and they
will discuss about that.
That is definitely--
I'm not committing that it will
be implemented, but it
certainly will be discussed.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And in some ways, I--
no, I guess you couldn't
do that.
I was going to say, I wonder
if you could inject some
script as a content script into
the WebView window, where
you could override some
of those things?
But that would be getting pretty
messy and not something
you'd really want to get into.
RENATO MANGINI: No, I think
you cannot do that.
You don't have the web requests
API that is available
to extensions.
So I can't think of a way
to do it, even a hack-y
way to do it now.
But this should be discussed
internally.
And I think it's the
same for the next
question, from Jarek also.
"Override user agent string,
override the cache module, and
define specific user
associates." I think the
answer is the same, OK?
It's a very compelling
use case.
You can emulate--
as you said, you can emulate
mobile browsers.
You can emulate other stuff
inside your Chrome packaged
app if you're doing
like an ID.
So it is a good use case.
I totally understand that.
So I hope that the engineering
team finds that it's possible
and feasible to do in the
foreseeable future.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Cool!
That's sort of the end of the
questions and the end of the
time we have for today.
I've put the link up to Renato's
Sublime plugin.
You can see it right there.
You can go grab that.
Check it out.
Let us know what you think,
provide your feedback.
Next week, we're going to be
joined by Paul Kinlan, who's
going to be joining
me to talk about--
what are we talking
about next week?
Oh, Third Party Authentication.
So one of the really cool things
about Chrome apps is
that it's really easy to go do
authentication up against the
Google services, right?
So you can go authenticate a
user and be like, yep, this is
Pete, and he's got this
Google account.
But not all services, obviously,
want to use the
Google authentication
providers.
You might want to use
somebody else's
authentication provider.
You may want to authenticate
against maybe Twitter or
foursquare or whatever.
You may want to authenticate
against those so that you can
go and do whatever you want to
do with those particular
service providers.
Now, we've got a set of APIs
that let you go in and
authenticate those, get the
set of cookies, do all the
OAuth stuff, all that
fun connection
that needs to happen.
So Paul and I are going to
dig into that next week.
Renato's actually got a great
post up on our Google+ page on
Chrome Developers that'll walk
you through some of the more
technical aspects and have
some samples and all
that kind of stuff.
So we'd love for you
guys to join us.
Same time next week, 9:00 AM
Pacific, noon Eastern, or
wherever that happens to
be, wherever you are.
With that, I want to
say thanks very
much for joining us.
Hope this was really
useful for you.
And thank you very
much everybody.
All righty, bye, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]